[Music]
y'all I can't believe I'm here right now
y'all are the best I'm so excited to be
here give it up for like the conference
organizers this is amazing so hi my name
is Kat March and I'm also at maybe cats
of the internet and I'm the lead
maintainer and architect for the NPM CLI
but I'm not here but I'm not here just
to talk about the NPM CLI on I'm gonna
talk about it I'm here to talk about a
little experiment I've been working on
called tink which I'm hoping will set a
precedent for JavaScript package
managers in the future but before I get
into the wat I want to talk a bit about
the why more specifically I want to talk
about what NPM needs to do in order to
get JavaScript apps to work and there's
really one big end goal we've had for
most of NPM x' lifetime put a bunch of
stuff into your local node modules as
fast as possible and have everything
consumed from there just make that as
fast as you can so that seems pretty
straightforward on its own but what does
it really take for context I want to
talk about the overall the overall
problem and what steps we've taken along
the way to mitigate the issues we came
up with that came up now the process I'm
going to describe is mostly shared
between all current package managers
they all do different optimizations and
clever things around each step but they
all kind have to do all of this at point
or another to be compatible with node so
let's take a look for this kind of
high-level overview of what a JavaScript
installer needs to do we all do this to
some extent or another or we have
different optimizations around it but
the concerns are ultimately the same
let's walk our victories through these
steps first up is this one reading local
dependencies if you have any you'll
probably notice this one these days when
you have like a no op install that is
when you run in p.m. even though you
literally just ran it and you're sure
all your depths are there and then cam
is still taking five seconds so you
don't know why it usually isn't more
than a couple seconds but it's still
pretty notice
yarn has an interesting optimization
around this where they just slap a
metadata file inside node modules based
on the hash of yarn lock and if those
match they say [ __ ] it and trust
whatever sin node modules which is a
perfectly valid optimization to make now
NPM has been a bit stubborn here since
we've so far considered that no up case
a fairly rare thing and if you run in pm
will be able to auto fix any issues with
your tree which we think is important
enough to warrant the delay I don't know
we might go ahead and do what yarn
doesn't some point anyway because people
just want that sweet sweet speed up but
you know in the end this step tends to
be noticeable but it's not really the
biggest delay but this next one kind of
was for awhile turns out making
literally thousands of requests just to
get metadata from the registry in order
to calculate our tree it's a fairly
network intensive operation and in times
of for NPM at five this was definitely a
time hog so like what happened
well basically lock files happened lock
files are super convenient for
developers sure but they're just a
single file cache oh my god what is
trying to update right now excuse me
they're just a single file cache of the
tree calculation step of your package
managers and that's why we love that
stuff so much once you've built your
project of none of your teammates really
need to bother even doing this step
until they add or remove any dependency
this is also why I'm pretty adamant that
you should use lock files even for
libraries they just like make life so
much easier
why are you frozen there we go
now this next one has never really been
a huge bottleneck on its own but I still
want to mention it because we do put
some effort into keeping this up being
fast enough and I want you all to know
that this stuff happens to exist long
story short this is what figures out
what existing dependencies on disk need
to be moved removed added copied
whatever since NPM at 3 we also do some
calculation to flatten that tree which
is fairly fast now but you know if you
how many of you used NPM at 3:00 when
first came out there's a handful it was
not the fastest thing on earth no it's a
lot faster now anyway moving on this one
here this one is by far the heaviest and
slowest of all the install steps mainly
because it's the heaviest on pretty much
all relevant resources let's dive a
little deeper into this one in the end
we have hundreds of megabytes that need
to be transferred over the network and
once we have those we have to spend a
bunch of CPU cycles parsing and gun
zipping guitar balls and when that's
done we move on to doing tons of discs
of heavy disk i/o because we're writing
all these files at disk literally all
three of the usual suspects are
bottlenecks here one way or another and
it all depends on your usage pattern is
some particular point in time so we can
just like ultimately optimize everything
long story short this is where all the
really bad and slow stuff happens and
this has been a huge target of
optimization for pretty much all package
managers in the JavaScript world and I
assume any other package managers too so
what can we do about this well for one
we can do a bunch of caching of tarballs
and different caching strategies have
different trade-offs MPM stores
Tarbell's themselves which takes up less
this space but it means that we have to
take the hit of parsing those tar balls
every time yarn stores them post
extraction which uses more disk space
but lets them do fast copies of all that
data instead of like re parsing the tar
balls every time the NPM here is really
interesting because they have an
extracted cache kind of like yarn but
instead of copying the files they hard
link them into their final destinations
this kind of surprisingly isn't really
that much faster than copying on like
SSDs and stuff but it's definitely way
more space efficient because you pay for
each package exactly once across your
system that's pretty cool and because I
can't seem to stop talking about yarn
today they have this thing called PNP
that partially addresses problems in
this step the downside is that you know
tools need to load a plugin and it
mostly works by fussing with the module
loader which can cause some
but still PNP is like really interesting
and definitely worth checking out and
I'm sure it's making like a lot of lives
easier already you can tell my Elle
about it you can have my I'll tell you
about it at the next talk he's great
so there's definitely a lot of work
going on to make this particular bit
better and you know no surprise is the
most expensive bit I'll get back to the
soon and what else we can do about it
but for now let's wrap this walkthrough
so we do all the downloading and
extracting and then we have to scan
through all the packages we just
installed and execute any run scripts
this isn't usually the biggest step
since there's usually opiate run scripts
that run and most of them aren't that
slow but this still becomes noticeable
on some unfortunate projects NPM doesn't
do this but some package managers
actually paralyze this step at great
risk and complexity but they pull it off
and it does make things a lot faster if
you have heavy stuff to build like ona
guruma which takes forever I think we're
better off with a solution with
something like note free kept or have
actual like pre-built binary somewhere
on the registry but that's what we got
right now maybe what you should take
away here though is that in the end node
modules is massive and also where dreams
go to die now the fact is that great
node modules while a great abstraction
has caused everyone massive headaches
and usability and time wasted in this
space abused there's a lot to agree on
to agree with on this front with like
Ryan's talk about node regrets here at
this conference
what are you doing microphone please
calm down um but what do we actually do
about it right it's easy to complain
about and talk about it how bad an idea
it is but I still think the good
outweighs the bad
like isolated dependencies are really
good like having each individual project
be able to manage some dependencies
fantastic being safe from dependency
hell is really good the fact that we
automatically nest things that's great
and you know we have
kind of 900,000 packages out there that
some of you might think that some of
them are crappy but most of them are
pretty useful at least a big enough
percentage of them are useful that we
want to keep that we want to have that
compatibility so and it's really on us
both package manager developers as well
as the larger community to do what we
can to make the most of this right I of
course have my own ideas about this and
I kind of hinted at what that was
already what I think we should do at
this point is move package management
itself directly into the runtime instead
of an external utility and that is what
tink is really about in the end but what
does this mean and what we what can we
actually do with it once we've done that
so this is this is what I'm talking
about you literally stop invoking node
yourself and you use this new tool
called tink instead it has a sub command
called shell that wraps node and adds a
few patches to FS to make it work it's
magic what magic
well virtual node modules the big idea
that if we control the runtime we
control what happens when someone tries
to read from node modules and once we
can do that at the runtime level all
sorts of things start happening it means
that we can get rid of all these copies
of node modules without changing the
module loader or the expected api's from
packages as far as any packages are
concerned they're accessing the
filesystem the same way they usually do
and this means it's compatible with
little details like underscore
underscore dear name like FS read file
Seng for reading configuration files and
literally all of that it just works out
of the box even even spawn sync even
even spawn works but if we're not in
node modules where are the files well
instead of copying them we keep them all
in a single global cache a lot like the
NPM does except we duplicate every
single file at the hash level that means
if you have five different versions at
the same package you'll only ever have a
few caller you'll only ever have new
copies for the files that actually
changed storing by hash can also make
reads very very fast for us but hey hey
we can do more since we control the
runtime why don't we just automatically
fetch dependencies for you as
meet them why don't we skip downloading
dependencies you're not using in your
current work tink is actually able to
block on reads that fail from the local
cache and inline fetch any packages you
haven't downloaded yet it makes note
work a bit more like a browser in that
front and yes before you say anything
there's a - - production flag to disable
this if you want to and make sure we're
not doing any random requests in
dependencies in production etc and of
course this means you don't do npm
install anymore you don't do npm install
and wait for things ever again
there we go yeah this is for it go for
it all you actually do is you do tank
add tink remove to add and remove
individual dependencies and you
otherwise don't worry about having an
install stuff anymore it all just gets
done automatically automatically by tink
asked needed it means if your coworker
pushed something and you pulled it you
just run it and it just kinda works and
you don't have to worry about it there's
no like conflicts to worry about our new
installs now you might be concerned
about this by the way patching FS itself
sounds really risky right but I'm not
that worried this is literally the same
approach that electron has taken and
they're very successful at it we can
also learn from their journey so I
believe this'll all work out in the end
in fact code some of the code to do this
in tink comes directly from electron and
I modified it further but wait there's
more there's other things that think
allows us to do now that we have runtime
control tink has typescript yes M wasm
and JSX support out of the box yeah all
right 63% are you kidding me how did
y'all how do you multiply it was like
40% last year it also runs a very cheeky
a very cheap checksum on every single
file it loads from no global cache so
you know that what you're getting out of
the cache the what you're getting into
your node is passing a hash tag a
checksum for every single load which is
fantastic it's super secure and if it
turns out or you ran the tank shell and
there's a missing dependency well and
single file was corrupted in your cache
even tink will just download and install
it for you and fix your and fix your
dependencies automatically you can turn
this behavior off in production but when
you're actually developing it's super
handy and finally my favorite part all
of this comes out of the box without the
need to configure or install anything
besides tink itself and I want to
emphasize this all of this comes without
the need for for any sort of loader
webpack it works test form works like
tap and just they'll work too and all of
this without any kind of loader or extra
flag or anything you install and run
things with tink and that's literally
all you need to do now let's do a brief
tool a brief tour the tool itself to
give you kind of an idea of what I'm
actually talking about this this year is
the core feature of the entire tool just
about everything I've talked about so
far it is available through this one
command remember you don't need to do NP
uninstall anymore that step is gone all
you do is run tink shell and all your
dependencies are fetched and extracted
as needed by the runtime runtime acid
execute our app this also works in the
interactive shell so it just blocks and
waits for things and you fetcher
dependencies and it just kind of goes I
I know I talked about performance a lot
before but a really strong guiding life
for me when working on NPM and tink has
been the idea of simplifying workflows I
want you to have to install and remember
as little as possible in order to be
productive I know that that's a big
problem in JavaScript these days where
you just install it feels like you
install half of NPM just to get started
the ability to just start running and
having the runtime take care of this is
super important to me in order to
achieve the workflow I think y'all
should have in your day-to-day in the
end I want the package manager to
disappear and not be something you have
to think about that's very important so
how many of you are familiar with NP x
here show of hands
yeah and the X go anyway King X like if
MPX it is this NP x for tink for the
recipe who don't know what MPX is it is
a tool that's bundled with NP x for
thenthen p.m.
self and one of the things it lets you
do is execute local binaries as well as
like temporary installations for example
if you install just as a dev dependency
instead of globally you can use NP x
jest to invoke your dev dependency
without needing to install it globally
you don't even need to configure a run
script for it you don't you have like
npm run tests or anything like that now
running your local bins through tank
exec think exact means that we can apply
the same logic to pre install anything
nexus necessary for your binary that
ting shell does for scripts but what if
you don't want to slow down your app
with package management stuff that's
where ting prepare comes in this command
goes ahead and does all the cache
warming beforehand and runs and installs
binaries delenda like for you so when
you run ting shell it just works as fast
as when you asked if you'd done an NPM
install or something beforehand you
could argue that this is the NPM install
of tink but it's important to note that
it's very much an optional step and it
might not even speed things up at all or
it might even make absolute time pass
slower like on CI you may as well take
the runtime hit up fetching dependencies
but what if you want to have an actual
node modules anyway like what if you
want to like inspects and use other
tools or your editor with which doesn't
understand think yet or whatever in this
case there's a nice command called
unwind that actually does a full
extraction into node module so you can
use your editor nan Deus build tools
pretty much anything in the usual way
this is basically an NPM install but
there's just like difference that I'll
go into next so what if you want to
debug a specific dependency instead of
installing a full tree well then you can
do tinker line and give it a dependency
and it'll only unwind that one
dependency plus its dependencies that
will let you patch things however you
want debug it etc and this is something
I want to emphasize because of the way
tink works anything inside node modules
itself takes precedence over the virtual
version and in fact if you use SSL right
file or a similar API tink will actually
create a physical file for you in node
modules which helps immensely with like
compatibility like if you have something
that randomly writes two node modules
that'll just work we'll just put a file
there for
don't don't worry too much about it now
this command is also done automatically
at the individual package level for any
dependencies that use install scripts
precisely to preserve compatibility
because you know no chip doesn't really
understand note itself so we actually
extract it but it's very few extractions
so since the closest thing to install
only builds existing dependencies how do
we add and remove dependencies besides
setting the package.json enter the
classic trio add remove and update
great fancy they do basically what it
says on the tin your you give them the
packages you add a remove they do it and
right on the you new package JSON and
package lock that JSON oh and by the way
all three of these become fully
interactive if you give them no
arguments
that means you'll be able to search
interactively for new dependencies and
pick them from a menu data for removing
and updating
yeah that's epic yeah interactive menus
[Laughter]
very exciting so the last command I'm
going to introduce a system check
utility the really cool thing about this
is that I want it's a one-stop shop for
all your verification and testing the
most noteworthy thing here is that it's
going to run your type script type
checks out of the box without needing to
install typescript acid dev dependency
if you do install it as a dev dependency
we'll use that version of it but it'll
still run it for you um but isn't it
nice to just be able to like go into a
project and type check the Tykes
type check the typescript out-of-the-box
lint it it's really nice um at this
point some of you might wonder if I've
been doing too much rust and cargo
lately and I think you'd be right but
this is an arrest conference so let's
move on rust is great so okay so where
do we go from here well first we have to
wrap up the prototype because it's
that's all it is right now a
proof-of-concept that should happen soon
enough
the next step is exciting we want to
build an open RFC based team that
includes more outside contributors than
we usually had in the npm CLI project
this will allow us to really hash out
inc and take it where it needs to go
together the RSC process will ensure
there's a community based approach to
growth and development and it means that
you can make a difference by
participating once that's all set we are
turning tink into n p.m. 8 that means
that in the future when you upgrade node
what used to be called tink will be
available out-of-the-box SNP em just
like current versions of NPM are you can
still use em PMS you usually do but if
you want to opt into this new workflow
the tool will be the tool will be there
for you
it'll also integrate with MPX meaning
all your MPX commands will run that much
faster finally once NPM at 8 is fix is
is shipped its and fixed it's a matter
of integrating it into node itself and I
look forward to working with the folks
over there to make this happen
I know it's a big step to be like
hacking FS itself so this kind of
requires a bit of API work on both ends
possibly but I'm sure we can make it
happen I totally left the TK TK in my
notes by the way anyway and there's one
more thing we are planning to release at
some point in the future a new package
fetching API and the new in the main NPM
registry this is exciting because
combined with pink or something similar
there's a good number of advantages and
this is where the exciting stuff stuff
happening that starts happening so just
to give you an idea this is why I think
it should be great the actual API is
fairly small it's a couple of new
endpoints that allow us to list files
available in a package and to fetch
those files individually by hat just
kind of like on package right um that's
it that's pretty much a new idea for the
API but what do we get from this well
for one some analysis on our end
estimates that it could involve up to
40% reduction in data transfer that
means your installs get a lot faster
they get done way faster it means that
if you're in a connection slower than
fiber you'll have less to wait for you
might actually finish your NPM install
before the heat death of the universe
it also means you'll store less stuff on
your system you won't need to download
read nice changelogs test code anything
like that you only download the files
that you actually use so this reduction
is mainly achieved by having pink shell
fetch files lazily so you only download
something when you first read it and
then when and then we cache it really
aggressively this is one of the most
exciting reasons to do things for me
finally there's one
this one's pretty interesting doing
things like this has the potato - hello
has the potential to completely change
how certain mono repo based libraries
work for example load action Babel as
you probably already know these
libraries involve a lot of sub tools
literally a hundred and forty second a
hundred and forty seven packages in the
babel mono repo so they just publish all
of this under the scope so folks don't
have to depend on the entire thing right
you don't want to have the entirety of
Babel you want red book or you want
maybe Babel CLI maybe a cup a handful of
other things no this can cause a lot of
problems for example users can have
issues keeping all packages in sync if
they depend on each other in some way on
the package publisher side this is a
really fragile setup because it makes
their publish process super prone to
like publish errors or timeouts and then
they need to make sure that they're able
to restart the entire publishing process
from where it failed and it just gets
nasty so all of these tiny packages have
to be released at the same time usually
all with the same version and then you
have to deal with the registry being
eventually consistent so not all
packaged versions might be available
when your user starts and selling them
and there's just chaos everywhere and
it's awful and everything and it NPM
starts airing on you and no one likes
that with tink and the new registry API
this wouldn't be necessary Eddie any
more lodash and babble would be able to
publish a single omnibus package way
more than most users would use but when
you install it would think it'll only
fetch the sub packages you're actually
using it using from within the big
package
everyone wins and you only have to have
one low - or babel item in your package
JSON instead of 12 different things
anyway that's not like I said this isn't
in progress yet but it's something we're
planning on doing because the advantages
are really clear to us are all around I
hope you enjoy it when it does happen in
completion think is exciting and also
it's kind of a work in progress I'm
sorry if you try and download it and it
explodes in your face
please keep away from flammable things
eight works by having a virtual node
modules that becomes your new runtime
it has typescript TSM JSX and wasm
support out of the
it'll be known as NPM eight when
released and we're gonna have a new and
unpackaged style registry API in the
future so you can help me tink happen
join us we can you can go to NPM docum
you slash c / development you can check
out the repo a 10 p.m. / tink on github
I am maybe cats on Twitter and Zeke ad
on github thank you
[Applause]
[Music]